breaking news here swella bravaman has
just been reappointed as Secretary of
State for the home office so swella
bravaman is going back to the home
office and it's just confirmed Grant
chaps as I was saying Grant shops is the
new business secretary so there you go
suela bravaman who backed Rishi sunak
this time around a very important
endorsement for him she was the leader
if you like of the right of the party he
has put her back in to her job in the
home office one of his top four
appointees so who's the top four in his
government
none of them actually his closest allies
actually Jeremy Hunt is chancellor he's
got Zoella bravaman as Home Secretary of
State in the home office and he's got
James cleverley again a Boris Johnson
pick as his foreign secretary and and is
close to the satellite uh in that top
group of people is actually Oliver
Dowden who is put into the cabinet
office it's the duchy of Lancaster so
there you go
uh there is uh suela bravaman's tweet uh
Zoella Braven has been appointed
Secretary of State for the home
Department as I said uh I'm Mark Austin
this is the NewsHour it's just gone uh
five o'clock and uh
and Rishi sunak is getting down to
business pretty quickly and putting
together his government and some of the
big offices of state are being filled uh
Jeremy Hunt is still the chancellor
James cleverley still
uh foreign secretary Ben Wallace I
should say we haven't mentioned uh for a
moment or two is still defense secretary
and swella bravaman
has got back the position that she had
which was uh Home Secretary so